enhance them in a environment soon many
thanks many thanks to the organizers for
opportunity to speak it's a great
pleasure and the start work with China
and with so-and-so keeper so let me
start with setting up what keeping hands
theorem is all about it's about
numerical range of a complex matrix well
I don't know it's something that but I'm
sure that many people are familiar with
probably know much more about than me on
the other hand maybe some people haven't
seen the definition at all it's it's the
simplest thing so you have a complex D
by D matrix and the numerical range is
simply the set of all values that that
you get from a by treating it lighter
and like a hermitian form Z to X star ax
and this gives you you run over all
vectors of length 1 this gives you a
subset of the complex plane and that's
the numerical range of this matrix okay
and so what kind of information does it
contain so first of all there's a
somewhat miraculous fact that this set
is convex so well there are so this is
the triplet tossed-off theorem which
that tells you that this is a convex
this is a convex set there are a number
of different proofs for this it's often
proved in in functional analysis for for
bounded operators on a hilbert space not
just for matrices there's also there's a
very nice proof in Bobby Knox textbook
on on convexity sort of puts that do
more general framework of because
quadratic convexity but no matter how
you prove it it's not I mean it's not
obvious it's not something where you you
know like convexity often is you just
apply the definition you do a convex
combination you see it no I mean it's
somewhat in somewhat non-trivial fact
that this is a convex subset of and more
generally so so what can you say about
it so first of all I mean if of course
if you have a hermitian matrix then just
take some real value
so then you get a real a real line
segment but this is even this is effing
only if so I mean emission matrix has
real eigenvalues but I mean just because
the matrix has real eigenvalues doesn't
mean it's hermitian right so this is one
way in which the numerical range always
contain already contains more
information than just just the
eigenvalues right
it is not invariant under similarity of
matrices it's not in very under under
Andrew Bates change so unlike the
eigenvalue so it captures in this sense
more more information about the matrix
itself so more generally if if a is a
normal matrix so if it commutes with the
adjoint then it's just the convex hull
of the eigenvalues so then it's a it's a
polytope but in general okay it's just a
complex it's just a convex subset of the
of the complex plane so the example that
I'm going to use for a next couple of
slides will be this lovely little 4x4
matrix you just shift and scale with 1 2
3 & 4 I already see Cynthia smiling she
likes to I know you like this so for
this matrix so this is not a normal
matrix and so ok so the numerical range
is a subset of the complex a it looks
like this
a lot of very exciting picture I mean
after all it's a complex called convex
subset of the plane so I mean how much
excitement can do but nevertheless so we
will see that it's even if this even for
this very simple example actually the
exact geometry of this subset of the
plane is not
spop was the picture s address so
alright so there are so there's a
hyperbolic curve associated with this
and that's the subject of this Kevin
Hart theorem so what you what you do is
you take your complex matrix and you
split it into real and imaginary part
and not coordinate wise but in this so
you take the matrix we are an imaginary
part which which works like this you do
okay a plus a star half and a minus a
star divided by 2 I and this so so this
makes it to a mission matrices right and
of course the truth be a is real part of
a times I times imaginary part and for
example so in this running example if
you do this so even though it's a little
I mean it's a little bit confusing well
I mean you start with the real matrix
but the real part of course it's not
that the imaginary part is 0 right
I mean in this case the real part and
imaginary part so they turn out Merson
matrices now that add up to a and so
what you can do now is so these are two
hermitian matrices now so so if I take
this determinant so you do x0 times the
identity plus x1 times the real part
plus x2 times the imaginary part and
because I have two hermitian matrices
and put the identity here this is a
hyperbolic pono meal ok this hyperbolic
with respect to 1 0 0 so which in this
particular case with these coordinates
just means that if you fix the last two
coordinates and let the first one run
then you
a real rooted polynomial and so this
will be so in fact I mean by the health
and Vinny cough so first of all of
course any determinantal polynomial in
three variables can be you could write
it in this way and then by helping
Vinnie cough this is really all all
hyperbolic point nominate since we
variables and so then this is familiar
picture of the curve of the curved
geometry so we look at this in the so I
mean this is supposed to be a projective
picture but really you can just you can
just assume that X 0 is equal to 1 okay
so which which leads to this kind of
picture it's a it's a slice of the
three-dimensional column where you put X
0 equal to 1 and type of velocity means
that the so the hypervelocity cone is
this the slice of type of velocity
cornice this convex region here in the
middle and geometrically hypervelocity
means that if you take any line you take
any line that passes through that bullet
city region you see only real only B
intersection which is I mean I'm sure
everyone has a little bit different from
the usual definition of hyper velocity
but that's why it comes out to if you
for these kind of plane this is an
example of degree 6 and was not a
running example so okay so what is the
statement of Kippen hans theorem so you
do this you start with your complex
matrix matrix you split it into real and
imaginary part you get a spectra he
drawn defined by these two hermitian
matrices and so what kept in hands
theorem what it says so
1951 may be one of the oldest theorem
involving hyperbolic polynomials in a
way well it says that the the numerical
range that we look at before in the
complex plane if you identify it with
with r2 then the numerical range is the
convex dual of this spectra he drew
and moreover it's given it is more
precisely it's the convex hull of the
dual curve of the plane curve defined by
by this point oval segment the way I
phrased that the statement has two parts
one is just this to destroy ality a
statement and this in fact is just it's
just general convexity I mean here in
this setup it's written down in a
slightly confusing way so it's maybe not
not obvious in the later and we look at
the more general part it will maybe be
more obvious but just possibly that so
the fact that this is the that the
numerical range is the convex dual of
this of this thing it's just general
convexity whereas the second part of the
statement that involves the the dual
curve this is the if you want the hard
part of the of the fear the worst is
towards the dual curve it's the dual
curve in the sense of projective
geometry not in the sense of convex
geometry so it just means it's the curve
that parameterize us all tangent lines
to to the curve right so you have dual
coordinates you have final coordinates
x0 x1 x2 if two coordinates u 0 u 1 u 2
and you look at lines with these with
these coordinates and you pick up all
all tangents to the given curve this
gives you a new curve in the dual plane
that's the dual curve and so let's do
this
yeah so we will get to that in a moment
that's exactly that's all it's all about
it yeah all right so what does what I
says exactly have to do with the convex
tool it's not so clear so so let's do it
and this okay so are there any questions
up - after you talk that you started
with the vectors of length one yes
that's part of the state okay let's look
at the example that I died so let's do
let's do this so if you do this you take
the determinant you get this this for
the boundary of the spectra he drew this
is the this curve of degree 4 and if
this is the picture here and it has this
this nice symmetry which comes from the
from the shift structure so that's the
the final curve and now you take the
dual curve and the dual curve so this is
a quartic the dual curve will have to
agree 12 in a moment and it's a degree
12 curve and in these you coordinates
and this is the T equation which you can
compute by elimination and this is its
this is the picture that you that you
see
and so so what if the so Wyatt doesn't
look so why does it look like this all
right so what is the meaning of the
picture so first of all exactly so this
was the picture that I showed you at
first but the inside was not visible in
America so by keeping hands theorem the
numerical range is the convex hull of
the dual curve that was the first
picture we had it's just a convex hull
of this thing so it's even somewhat
stronger I mean the drew curves I mean
the dual polynomial vanishes on the
whole boundary of the of the so this is
what you what you see and so this stuff
in here that contains the more
interesting geometry if you want so I
mean this comes the outer elbow comes
from the little convex region that we
really care about in this takes care of
the rest
and it's singular which is what always
happens the blue curve of a unless it
unless for conics the blue curve of a of
a smooth plane curve has singularity in
the singularities have a meaning so you
get you get nodes where the curve
crosses crosses through itself for by
tangent lines of the original curves all
right so here you have a line that's
tangent twice to the original curve oh
and if you think about it it's as the
tangents move along the curve this will
mean that the dual of passes through
itself it's geometrically it's kind of
suggested so so you get nodes that come
from the by tangent lines and you also
get cusps like here and the cusps come
from the inflection points of the arise
when you when you go to when you go
through so this is eight cusps and they
come from the eight inflection points
that's it
that's the that's the job exactly so
this I got happen on the you you're very
good at predicting what I'm gonna say
next
so this is exactly so this will be on
the on the next slide so there's to say
this again in general was if you start
with a small a smooth curve in the plane
then the dual will be irreducible but
not be smooth but will be able to
support degree e times P minus 1 and
generically you see two types of
singularities you see the the nodes
coming from the right-hand runs and you
see the cusps coming from the inflection
and indeed so classically so there are
the clicker formulas a classical
geometry that that count that counties
these singularities so for generic curve
if you do the count over the complex
numbers these are the formulas so you
get 1/2 D times D minus 2 Plus 3 nodes
correspond to by tangents and you get 3
D
so but this is of course I mean it's a
complex count of course so this is for
the complex curve and so in a second it
will become somewhat relevant what
happens over the reals not with the
count but nevertheless so I mean if you
want to do this counter with the wheels
so what is known what is also very
classical is that you can have at most
it was the third of the inflection
points can be it can be real but how
many bad hand runs are we oh is somewhat
in general your can be real is somewhat
harder to know degrees but I don't think
that even exact typically you can have
all of the bad engines wheel or or maybe
you if you of them
[Music]
so really one so this is the plain
statement again of Kip enhance theorem
and I really also want to treat this
plain case carefully and explain explain
the idea of the proof so why does why
should this be true so if you look at it
sort of proof by picture its it actually
is the whole thing actually is very
simple so you want to say that to do the
convex dual of this thing in the middle
which is the spectral heat one that we
wanted you want to say that that will
just be the convex hull of the dual
curve okay so why is that well so this
means basically that this this I mean
this boat do lies to some convex over
again that's clear and you want to say
that everything else will be inside this
and why is that true it's true because
if you have tangents somewhere to the
curve somewhere else
and so what does it mean in the dual to
be outside of this of this over while
the points outside correspond to lines
that pass through the central region and
if you're a hyperbolic a tangent
somewhere outside cannot pass through
the interior here so this is the picture
suggests it emits it's a general fact
about hyperbolic polynomials which is
extremely useful that for lines through
the hyperbole through the hyperbola
city-region not only all the
intersection points real but you
actually cannot become tangent anywhere
okay this is down derivatives of course
but also about geometrically that's what
it means okay you cannot become tangent
anywhere else and that's the that's the
reason why I mean since you can't become
tangent for any lines through here
that's the reason by everyone everything
else stays stays inside that's why the
theorem is true however so if you really
want to make this into into a proof
there's some there is a nagging detail
which is that so this is all good and
well for the things that actually come
from smooth point smooth real points
okay but this remember that the
definition was a complex a construction
so so in particular what you what you
wouldn't see in the picture so what
happens so the worrying thing is what
happens you could have some nodes some
real nodes that are isolated
singularities of the rule and you
wouldn't okay and so what happens to
those why can they not show up so for
example so I can do I can certainly do
an example where you you do get such
isolated notes so here's a here's
another example which looks at first
even more boring so this is just this is
another Coretech where you really just
have two convex ovals okay so absolutely
nothing happens in the this was the
final picture this was the dual picture
it picture looks exactly the same this
is again the equation this is a degree
12 curb it's not hyperbolic of course
but it still just has to 200 volts but
actually if you look more closely it so
happens this thing has this thing there
has four real by tangents that don't
look like by it handles so these are for
real lines but they are tangent to to a
pair of two well two pairs of complex
conjugate point by tangents their
attention are two pairs of complex
conjugate points that also a valid by
tangents according to the algebraic
definition unfortunately and it leads to
nodes on the dual curve and these nodes
Mathematica didn't plot them because
they're isolated points but you can find
them these nodes are isolated isolated
real points therefore isolated
singularities of this to a curve but
again they do lie they do all gather
nicely in the inside of the outer
although for much the same geometric
reason as before if you are if you are
align the passes through the
hypervelocity region you can't be
complement be tangent at real points you
can even less be tangent at complex
points but because of intersection
points are we so definitely these
singularities they will not they will
not show up inside the inside the convex
hull
but the only reason I emphasize this
this so much is that this the subtlety
this interplay between the complex and
the real curve this is exactly what will
make make life much harder if you go
away from from curves so for curves at
all it's all good and so I hope you all
agree with this so I mean I've now told
you all the ingredients that are needed
to turn the pictures into an actual
proof ok this is the reason why that's
yes this is just so this would just mean
right but they could I mean it would
just mean that despite engines so it
can't happen in degree 4 right but it
would mean that despite hands and
somehow cuts through the curve not food
you know over but cut through the curve
somewhere and of course in higher degree
that could happen it's here is degree 4
so they really have to stay outside but
they're happily degree 4 but in higher
degrees yes yes it can happen they can
travel somewhat to the outside but they
can't really escape the outer all
arguing that everything indeed I was
arguing everything was is in the inside
right but where does everything come
from so everything means all the real
points ok but the real points can I mean
the real points in the Drule where do
they come from they can they come from
real lines but the real lines don't have
to be tangent to real points so the
argument that I was making before okay
well you just you look at the outer
ovals and he moved the line lines around
a bit this was not completely rigorous
for this reason right there are also
real lines that are tangent but they're
not tangent in real points so then ok
you had uniqueness refined for this
situation you need is refined argument
that's that's the reason ok
so I can certainly produce about a
shorter Thunder actually you could
certainly produce a picture of something
that's not hyperbolic okay but still
you'll get a nice convex you know oval
and all the just looking at the real
points the geometry works out nicely but
then in the dual you would get such a
such an isolated point outside and the
convex hull would be one example perhaps
this could definitely happen okay and
the reason we say it's again the reason
is that so the real points of the dual
curve they correspond to real lines
actual real lines there are tangent to
the curve but the points of tangency do
not have to be real points that's the
thing that's tricky between between the
real and the complex geometry right is
that the tangency is there but you may
not see it in the real picture
so it's a question that statement falls
for a genius yes so yeah so I made
everything homogeneous right so so if
you look at the equations I'm giving all
their curves are homogeneous what the
equation so in my definition all the
curves are homogeneous which is a little
contrary to this to the setup actually
you want X 0 to be equal to 1 IMAX sort
of point is to slap this under the rug
but this you have to do this going back
and forth between the cones or the
projective variety and these these
slices that we that we care about but
this is if you would carefully just
believe me that all the statements will
you have to I mean the or the curve
theoretic statements and so on that are
made of a protective curves and they are
not really true so it only depends on
the on the curve so you could yeah you
could look at different determinants or
representations of the same curve coming
from your original matrix and I think
people have actually looked at this
general Marquez Otto it's not so clear
how this I mean how are these new mate
matrices that represent the same curve
how are they related to the original
matrix that you wanted the numerical
range off I mean not in any obvious way
except that they have to say numerical
range it's only obvious because they you
know that they get the same curve
are these what happens if you take
unitary cause you get the matrix per
unit rate so the numerical range doesn't
change these variance things you yeah
just to conceivably also possible to see
directly because again it's a little
tricky because you're doing I mean
you're doing transformations on this
beyond imaginary part
okay so this is what I was going to say
about the case of plane curves and I
really I mean in higher dimensions I
really want to get to only two one one
punchline result so before I go on so
I'll be all happy with the original
Cap'n hands theorem and the plane case
okay so now we go to higher dimensions
and this means we'll look at the joint
numerical range of of several matrices
and in fact in this case we are going to
assume that the matrices are already
hermitian the P star so you know
commercial matrices but more than one
mission matrices a 1 to a n and then we
can look at the same thing as before but
for all the matrices together so we just
do X star a 1 X 2 X star a and X for X
of length X of length 1 and we get
something in C to the N I'm sorry we get
some I'm sorry we get something emission
matrices we get something out to the end
this is the type of this is the point
this is what we say we take our mission
matrices so of course now we are in our
to the N and so in this case so what
happens so first of all so what does
this thing mean so this destroyed
numerical range it's a little bit less
so from the original motivation say it's
a little less what information exactly
it encodes about these about the
matrices it's been studied in in in
matrix analysis our co-author stefan
vice so he comes from mathematical
physics and this seems to be where most
of the interest currently comes from so
people look at this in in quantum
physics as a statistical model for the
for the state space of a quantum system
but I'm really I mean I'm really just
saying words so I shouldn't advertise
this were just saying was that I hardly
hardly understand so I'll just I'll stay
away from the quantum physics but this
is for some of the motivation and recent
studies of this thing comes from so
sadly if you if you first the first
thing that you notice is if you do this
in I mean the triplets hostel theorem
does not transfer so this thing will not
be convex in general so this has been
looked at in some in some
so sometimes it still is convex you can
produce cases where it stays very
special cases where it does stay convex
but in general this will just not get a
convex set so nevertheless you can I
mean you can't just take the I mean we
can just take the convex hull and it's
easy to describe it in the same in the
same term so here I'm just taking
vectors of length one I can rewrite this
in terms of a of a trace right so so if
I write this mister trace then this
becomes a 1 xx star X star is a Rank 1
positive semi definite matrix of twice 1
so if you start taking convex hulls of
these things you will just end up with
this so you take the trace the scalar
part after a 1 with X we'll access any
hermitian PSD matrix of twice what okay
so that's what the convex hull will be
and and this thing of course this is
something that we feel very familiar
with so this is this is just a linear
projection of the cone of PSD matrices
okay how mission matrices but
nevertheless PSD matrices this is so
this is a spectral heat will travel and
more specifically it's it's actually
just the dual again this is due orders
to the spectra here and then this sends
it the same as before this is the dual
this is the convex dual of of just the
spectra he draw the spectra he drew and
put the identity here so the identity
will give me this trace equal one
condition when you do a lies and then
you just take this
spectra here on defined by these n
hermitian matrices joint numerical range
is the convex dual of T so maybe I
should say the convex hull of the joint
numerical range I should say that the
terminology seems a little bit in flux
at this point so some people call this
convex how their joint numerical range
and some people call this the troy
numerical range don't call this the
spatial numerical range
I really know what what you call it but
to be perfectly clear I will just say
it's the convex hull of the drawing
numerically in anyway this convex hull
is the is just a dual of this of the
spectrum what do you mean the right hand
side I think the convex hull because
I've now des is flying one matrices this
would be if I put X of Rank 1 here okay
but I'm taking the convex hull and then
I just get all permission matrices of
twice like they also this form right yes
but for rank one matrices I'm just
taking a vector here X in C n so this is
clearly a subset of this but here I've
taken the convex the convex hull because
I'm a la matrices of
so this is so okay so whatever this is
it's still just a dual of this of this
spectral Headroom and so now so now the
question is can we still do something
like in the like in Koeppen hands so I
mean where other t4 spectra hito is not
so not so bad we do this an ST HTP all
the time you have a dual if you have an
SDP have a dual STP but that that's in
fact does not mean that you have very
good control of the dual column of the
even in the spectra he go case this does
not actually give you an immediate
description of the dual cone so so the
question is would be do we still get
this statement from Cap'n hands - um so
can we still combine this with with the
duality of protective varieties and take
the convex hull okay this will be the
same thing as in the plane so the
general definition of the dual variety
now is very much like four coils you
have any you have a projective variety V
and you just take all hyper planes that
are tangent to the to the varieties of a
variety itself is not it's not of core
dimension one so then that I mean it's
tangent space as a lower dimensional but
you just take all hyper planes that
contain the tangent space at some
regular points do you take all hyper
planes that are tangent to - they're
given variety V in some regular point
right so definition says there exist
some regular point where the tangent
space is contained in this hyper plane
defined by this equation and you collect
all these coordinates you get the dual
variety in the dual projective space and
this behaves I mean just behave somewhat
similar to the case of plane curves so
so here's some facts so the first a song
a statement about this so if V is is
irreducible we still get still I didn't
actually say this for curves but you get
you have by reality so the dual of the
drool
is is the give'em is the original
variety anything that doesn't satisfy
this from be called it well it right but
it's actually not easy to prove so so
for curved stairs to someone I mean even
for curves it's a little bit surprising
at first because the degree goes up at
the duel as we saw right a degree if we
established move saying the degree jumps
from D to D times t minus one and now if
you do reality again that the you eat
suddenly drops but that's of course
because the dual curve is not smooth and
the same thing happened to you so you do
get by duality so this is for instance
it's in the textbook of Calvin kept an
oven and the Levinsky is the proof of
this general bite while he theorem I
actually don't know when this was first
when this was first proved in full
generality I mean some special cases so
many classical known but what you see
and again so in the generic case it's it
kind of behaves like you would expect
for curves so if you start with a
hypersurface and it's generic random
then the dual is is again a hypersurface
of some higher degree degree d times but
the drift in contrast to curves the
situation that we care about with the
spectra Hedra so determinantal hyper
surfaces are not generic in this
innocence so in fact a highly non
generic so determinantal hyper surfaces
usually they contain linear subspaces
the hyper surface contains in your
subspaces and this means that you get
less degrees of freedom in in the
tangency and it means that the dual
variety the dimension collapses so in
fact the most i mean the most extreme
example of this is to you if you just
take the the general determinant okay if
you just take the the general
determinant so you can think of it as a
hyper surface in the space of all
symmetric peabody matrices you take all
matrices symmetric matrices of rank
less than D this is some this is the
determinant all hyper surface
and what and the dual of this is just
the set of all symmetric matrices of
rank one so which is in algebraic
geometry is the veyron is a variety so
so this has dimension in particular this
has dimension well T plus 1 choose 2
minus 1 the determinant will
hypersurface and this has dimension D so
the dimension collapses completely and
if we start taking if we go to general
spectra heat was we start slicing this
thing and we'll see some sunburn of the
same phenomenon of dimension grow and so
without all this even without all this
protective this general facts about
duality so people studying the joint
numerical range they did look at look at
this ok let me first all right I forgot
about the slides let's just it's just
too nice not to mention so so it's a
famous classical example just to see
some nice variety in duo variety a
famous classical example is this to
destroy ality between a cubic singular
cubic surface in P 3 just Kaylee's cubic
finding the a laptop as a spectra he
drawn and it's dual surface is the is a
quartet surface in this case so the
degree goes up not by so much because
it's a singular surface but the dual is
a quadric surface and it's this blue
thing here it's the cortex surface which
is tool 2
well if you want to do a convex body
exactly so what happens is this thing is
not convex actually so if you wanted
their convex so if you want their
conducts do all of this thing there will
be some part when you take the convex
hull of the dual you will have some
cutter I have to have some cut off so
you have to get the convex tool you have
to put some lids on this thing okay you
have to put some hyper planes you have
to put four hyper planes corresponding
to these four singular points they will
sit like lids on the on the protective
tool to give the convex tool thanks just
oh it's all yeah exactly so so it shows
exactly the kind of phenomenon we want
if we wanted the convex to all of the
spectra he drawn here it's it's fine to
take the convex hull of the do a variety
but you really do need to take the
convex hull unlike for the curved
example before it is not just vanished
on the whole boundary of the but not
really I mean they come from the now
they don't I mean they come from it a
little bit they are dual to these four
points but this is not they are not on
the blue variety of those lines yes yes
I mean the whole picture is so yeah I
didn't think this will you're right i
they're all pictures cannot sterically
cut off right so when you do actually
get yes you do exactly so yeah I should
have noticed this before this is exactly
what we're gonna see now also in the in
the matrix examples
exactly so let me show the same
phenomenon in the example that I
prepared for that purpose I sort of
inverted this at the last minute and
didn't think thinking through your part
right actually it also has a wall
unexposed the extreme points oh yes yeah
it's a dual the respect when he drone
it's not respectful he'd going it's no
it's not affix post
yeah I thought wrong tree is okay yeah
it's this tiny example endlessly
fascinating okay so without all this
nice classical projective geometry so
people looking at the joint numerical
range already discovered sort of the
same thing happening okay so China mecha
taco who a lot of work on this on
numerical the numerical range from Troy
numerical ranges so they just cover this
this example that Kip on our theorem
will will fail and higher dimensions for
much the same reason so they gave this
explicit example of three hermitian
matrices where if you so well this is
the determinant of hyper surface that
bounds the corresponding spectra he
drawn they computed the dual and they
notice that the dual variety is singular
along a line contained in particular
contains this entire line and this of
course will wreak havoc with taking
convex hulls okay so so here's the
picture so there's this part of the
thing which is nice and smooth and that
actually is the dual of the spectrum but
then we also get this this this line so
if you just may eevee wheelie say I take
the convex hull of the blue variety no
matter how you do this then you this
line will will destroy the statement
that you actually want okay so you have
to get rid of the line before taking you
have to remove the line and then the
picture is fine
so and yeah okay I just have enough time
to get to the to the punch line so
that's indeed so the happy ending to
this story is that this is exactly this
is the only thing that goes wrong so
this is incomplete incomplete generality
doesn't even rely on spectra Hedra if
you start with the hyperbolic a
hypersurface
and you take the and you take the
protective dual variety no matter
whether it's a hypersurface again or not
in these examples it was but as I've
showed you it doesn't have to be but you
take the projective to a variety and
then the convex hull of its real points
will still give you the convex dual of
the hyperbola city cone but you have to
first remove or singular point of the
dual okay so so this kind of thing
whenever you see something like this in
real algebraic geometry when you have a
lower dimensional part where the local
dimension is lower in particular this
means that this that these will all have
to be singular points of this of this
but no matter what they are like so you
have to be if you remove all
singularities from the dual hyper
surface then the convex hull will still
be the correct
I said will be dual to the hyperbola
silicon so in particular in some sense
this does give a description of the
joint numerical range so if you take the
joint numerical range of formation
matrices and you take the dual hyper
surface to the determinant of hyper
surface you next I will give you the
joint America
andwell okay and and the proof I mean
the proof relied on a more careful
analysis of what happened of what
happened much more careful analysis of
what happened in the plane but we saw I
mean at least most of the ingredients
already in the plane case you have to
keep track carefully of what it means
for a real point on the draw from what
kind of real thing in the final can it
actually come and then will you take
closures you have to make sure that
everything gives gives the same thing as
four planks and okay I mean this is some
so okay there's a some description of
this joint numerical arrangement I think
in complete generality there's probably
not much it can be improved much what we
don't know is whether for instance well
there whether there are nice conditions
on the on the matrices that would
prevent this this kind of counter
examples of where you well you don't
have to worry about the singularities
but I don't know what those conditions
would so I'll stop here in the basic
situation suppose you start with falling
homes in one there would make its
companion makers
yeah it's a non-symmetric my way of
studying the roots of a polynomial
the eigenvalues are still the roots so
there are some of the general statements
apply so it will contain the roots of
the polynomial and then I have a second
question more general could you imagine
any kind of generalization to positive
be hyperbolic varieties this is a face
one face K you know which can be maybe a
K times even o P is Frankie Ryan Kate
Mary says yes yes so so I mentioned
exactly so I mentioned this I didn't we
didn't really look at this but I
mentioned so there are these people who
study a convexity of this thing right so
my uh skip pastures sorry about this
I actually lien poon so they have this
for they did this analysis of convexity
of the joint numerical range and they
looked at exactly what you suggested so
what if I don't go from Rank 1 to the
convex howl all at once but what if you
do it step by step what can you say when
does it first become convex they have
some general statements but I I mean at
least as far as convexity is concerned
as far as I remember nothing too
surprising happens so in meaning meaning
you can have examples where you have to
go all the all the way to square
matrices and you can have examples where
it immediately becomes convex and then
you can sort of forget many things in
between depending on it is a natural
thing to look at yes
any more questions
[Applause]